je vous le dis on va faire un petit tour
tromperie qui a déjà surpris son
conjoint dans le lit avec une autre
personne franchement comme toi ça déjà à
l'essai pierre simard et je ne peux pas
vous dire qui c'est mais c'était il ya
une tête pour trouver une pierre qui
elle était en train de tourner à
vancouver et c'était son anniversaire
j'étais à paris j'étais moi aussi en
tournage et il ya une journée de
tournage qui a annulé donc qu'est ce que
je fais je prends l'avion paris montréal
montréal vancouver ou pont couvert
j'arrive je vivais chez un fleuriste je
prends des fleurs je vais l'attendre
dans son hôtel et là j'arrive à l'hôtel
et qu'est ce que je vois elle en train
d'embrasser le producteur sur la bouffe
devant la réception koala et j'ai passé
tout le mobilier de la chambre par
l'avant et après sur parti la queue
entre les jambes je peux tu ne manges
plus donc depuis de tata qui je ne mange
plus de t'attaquer
[Rires]
arrivé tu bois sac et super tube aller
voir où tu paies sont mon oreille mais
dans ces cas là dessus et nuls
mais quoi qu'il arrive teddy soit et
violent et ce n'était pas mon cas soit
tu fais même pas rembourser le billet
d'avion et on l'a quitté non là l'été
elle était en train de me quitter tous
des choses là il y avait plus de
discussions possibles chien